[Music]
hello to all viewers welcome to this
very special episode of what's up prof
this will be an in-depth study so
without wasting any time over to alter
today we are going to talk about a very
serious issue and it took me a long time
to come to the point where I thought
perhaps it is time that we spoke about
some of the things that we will be
speaking about before we start let us
just bow our heads in prayer our loving
Heavenly Father we are living in such
momentous times and people are concerned
and want to know what saith the Lord
so Heavenly Father I pray that you will
help us through this lecture that your
Holy Spirit will guide us and that we
will come to conclusions which are
biblical and based upon your word and
upon the leading of your spirit we thank
you and we praise you in Jesus name Amen
the title of this lecture is is this the
end and I was interested to see that the
Express the home of the daily and Sunday
Express asked that same question end of
the world is coronavirus the prophesied
plague in the book of Revelation and
then they states in this article the end
of the world will be preceded by
widespread pestilence and plague
militant Christians reading the Bible's
Book of Revelation have claimed could
this plague from the Bible be the corona
virus epidemic sweeping around the globe
and then finally after writing about
these issues they come to the conclusion
there is however nothing to suggest the
corona virus is biblical in nature and
not simply a manageable epidemic now I
tend to agree with them
on the other hand we are told to look
for the signs of the times and people
have been asking is this the end is this
the beginning of the end and what are
the signs of the end and is there any
indication about how long the world will
still continue and we need to talk about
some of these issues and I think we're
going to stick our necks out a little
bit but let's see where this leads us
the first question I would like to
address is should we be studying the
signs of the times now be using quite a
few quotes from the spirit of prophecy
and I believe that this church has been
blessed with this special gift to steer
it through the times that we are living
in the spirit of prophecy is not to
supersede the Bible the spirit of
prophecy is to make that which is
sometimes a little bit obscure in the
Bible very plain and it leads us back to
the greater light which is the Word of
God so we need to base what we believe
on the Word of God but if God has seen
fit to give us the special gift we can
also consult it she writes our ministers
are not doing their whole duty the
attention of the people should be called
to the momentous event which is so near
at hand she's talking about the coming
of Christ the signs of the times should
be kept fresh before their minds the
prophetic visions of Daniel and John
foretell a period of moral darkness and
declension but at the time of the end
the time in which we are now living the
vision was to speak and not lie when the
signs predicted begin to come to pass
the waiting watching ones are bidden to
look up and lift up their heads and
rejoice because their Redemption draweth
nigh so rather than a mess
of doom and gloom there is a message of
rejoicing and looking up and we are to
study the signs of the times and we are
supposed to make them prominent that
means we must be in tune with what is
happening in the world now many believe
that when you do these things and you
correlate the signs of the times with
the Bible that you are busy with
conspiracy theories nothing could be
further from the truth we need to know
where we stand in the stream of time in
the visions of the night
a very impressive scene passed before me
I saw an immense ball of fire fall
amongst some beautiful mansions causing
their instant destruction I heard
someone say we knew that the judgments
of God were coming upon the earth but we
did not know that they would come so
soon others with agonized voices said
you knew why then did you not tell us we
did not know on every side I heard
similar words of reproach spoken if we
do not speak when we have knowledge that
very few people have then God will hold
us accountable when it came to the first
coming of Christ she writes in the book
the great controversy which by the way
everybody should read if they can get
hold of it it was not the scholarly
theologians who had an understanding of
this truth and engaged in its
Proclamation referring to the first
coming of Christ had these been faithful
Watchmen diligently and prayerfully
searching the Scriptures they would have
known the time of night the prophecies
would have opened to them the events
about to take place but they did not
occupy this position and the message was
given by humbler men Jesus said walk
while you have the light lest darkness
come upon you John 12:35 those who
away from the light which God has given
Oni Glick to seek it when it is within
their reach or left in darkness but the
Savior declares he that followeth me
shall not walk in darkness but shall
have the light of Life John 8:12 whoever
is with singleness of purpose seeking to
do God's will earnestly heeding the
light already given will receive greater
light to that soul some star of heavenly
radiance will be sent to guide him into
all truth God wants us to know this is
not a cosmic secret God wants it
proclaimed that the coming of Christ is
near it was needful that men should be
awaken to their danger that they should
be roused to prepare for the solemn
events connected with the close of
probation now we're moving to the end of
time the prophet of God declares the day
of the Lord is great and very terrible
and who can abide it who shall stand
when he appeared who is of purer eyes
than to behold evil and cannot look on
iniquity Chhotu 11 Habakkuk 1:13 to them
that cry my god we know thee yet have
transgressed his covenant and hastened
after another god hiding iniquity in
their hearts and loving the paths of
unrighteousness to these the day of the
Lord is darkness and not light even very
dark and no brightness in it has they'e
8/2 and then Psalm 16 for Amos 5:20 it
shall come to pass at that time says the
Lord that I will search Jerusalem with
candles and punish the men that are
settled on their Lee's that say in the
heart the Lord will not do good neither
will he do evil Zephaniah 1:12 I will
punish the world for their evil and the
wicked for their iniquity and i will
cause the arrogancy of the proud to
cease and I will lay low though
enos of the terrible as ayah 13 11
neither their silver nor their gold
shall be able to deliver them your
riches will not be able to spare you
from this time of trouble that is upon
us their good shall become a booty and
their houses of desolation Zephaniah
1:18 and 13 we need to understand the
times we are living in they are very
serious and God is seeking for a people
that will be prepared to live according
to his covenant now many people are
saying do not make it so prominent be
careful how you say these things
there's no need of milk of the souls
have been convinced of the truth as soon
as the conviction of truth is yielded to
and the heart willing the truth should
have its effect the truth will work like
leaven and purify and purge away the
passions of the natural heart it is a
disgrace for those who have been in the
truth for years to talk of feeding souls
who have been months in the truth about
upon milk it shows they know little of
the leading of the Spirit of the Lord
and realized not the time we are living
in those who embrace the truth now will
have to step fast they will have to be a
breaking up of the heart before the Lord
a rending of the heart and not the
garments a reference to the Jewish
custom of rending one's garments as a
sign of great grief we need to speak the
truth unadulterated people need to know
where we stand in the stream of time
because God's Spirit is gradually being
withdrawn from this world the days in
which we live or solemn and important
the Spirit of God is gradually but
surely being withdrawn from the earth
plagues and judgments already falling
upon the despisers of the grace of God
the calamities by land and sea
the unsettled state of society the
alarms of war or pretentious they
forecast approaching events of the
greatest magnitude the agencies of evil
are combining their forces and
consolidating they are strengthening for
the last great crisis great changes are
soon to take place in our world and the
final movements will be rapid ones
testimonies volume 9 page 11 now these
things are unfolding before our eyes we
need to be aware of where we stand in
the stream of time people are saying
surely this will all go away and then
we'll have a time of peace and things
will go back to normal we need not get
up into a state of excitement at this
stage the spirit of Anarchy is
permeating all nations that's an
important point and the outbreaks that
from time to time excite the horror of
the world about indications of the pent
up fires of passion and lawlessness that
having once escaped control will fill
the earth with woe and desolation the
picture which inspiration is given of
the antediluvian world represents to
truly the condition to which modern
society is fast hastening even now in
the present century and it professor to
Christian lands their crimes daily
perpetrated as black and terrible as
those for which the old world sinners
were destroyed before the flood God sent
Noah to warn the world that the people
might be led to repentance and thus
escaped the threatened destruction as
the time of Christ's second appearing
draws near the Lord sends his servants
with a warning to the world to prepare
for that great event multitudes have
been living in transgression of God's
law and now he and mercy calls them to
obey it
sacred precepts all who will put away
their sins by repentance towards God and
faith in Christ offered pardon this
world is so steeped in iniquity we hear
little pieces here and we hear little
pieces there and the world is appalled
this view was given in 1847 when there
were but few of the Advent Brethren
observing the Sabbath and of these but
few supposed that its observance was of
sufficient importance to draw a line
between the people of God and
unbelievers now the fulfillment of that
view is beginning to be seen the
commencement of that time of trouble
here mentioned this is important does
not refer to the time when the plagues
shall begin to be poured out but to a
short period just before they are poured
out while Christ is in the sanctuary at
that time while the work of salvation is
closing trouble will be coming on the
earth and the nations will be angry yet
held in check so it's not to prevent the
work of the third angel at that time the
latter rain or refreshing from the
presence of the Lord will come to give
power to the loud voice of the third
angel and prepare the Saints to stand in
the period when the seven last plagues
shall be poured out in a previous
discussion on what's up broth
I made the statement that we are
possibly in the little time of trouble
in other words this short period of time
before the plagues will be poured out is
that a possibility
or is that fear-mongering let us
carefully study and find out where we
are in the stream of time here is a
German
News metropole news which says that
millions of pictures and videos of six
traffic with little children have come
to the fall and there was an operation
called Operation Gargamel which is
beginning which is showing that the
world is so steeped with iniquity that
any sensible person would become a pole
trafficking little children Pizza Gate
if we study the iniquity that goes on
even in the most highest ranks of
society then we are appalled it is time
for God to act and he will not much
longer tolerate this kind of activity in
the world the world is evil beyond
measure things like cannibalism blood
sacrifices the drinking of blood of
juveniles for rejuvenation these are
common things in the news today and
humanity is appalled we are living in
the times that it was in the days of
Noah and if anything we are probably
worse at the stage I was shown the
inhabitants of the earth in the utmost
confusion war bloodshed privation want
famine pestilence were abroad in the
land my attention was then called from
the scene they seemed to be a little
time of peace once more the inhabitants
of the earth were presented before me
and again everything was in utmost
confusion so it is quite possible that
the events unfolding at the moment might
again recede and we
have an apparent moment of quiet and
peace at least I hope so so that the
gospel can do its work
but then my attention was called upon
the scene they seemed to be a little
time of peace and then once more the
inhabitants of the earth were presented
before me and again everything was in
utmost confusion strife war bloodshed
with famine and pestilence raged
everywhere other nations were engaged in
this war in confusion war caused famine
want and bloodshed caused pestilence and
then men's hearts failed them for fear
and for looking upon those things which
are coming upon the earth so we have the
beginnings we have little moment of
peace and then we have an escalation
which will finally lead to the final
events now the question we need to ask
ourselves what are the signs we should
be looking for this is important well
both Jesus and Daniel refer to the
abomination which causes desolation as
one of the great signs God's people in
the time of Jesus were to look out for
the abomination that causes desolation
and this was a dual application prophecy
and at the end of time there will be a
fulfillment of the exact same scenario
just in a universal setting on a
spiritual level let's have a look at
this Daniel 11 verse 31 and arms shall
stand on his part because jesus said we
must study the Book of Daniel and they
shall pollute the sanctuary of strength
now the sanctuary of course stands for
the plan of salvation how the plan of
salvation is to unfold where you brought
the lamb and where you confessed your
sins over the land and the land was
sacrificed and became as it were a type
of the great sin bear
who would come Jesus Christ and then it
led you to the Laver and then into the
Holy where Jesus is the light of the
world where the bread of his presence is
there the bread that we are to take into
our lives and into our very thinking and
which is to change us into what we are
into those who follow Christ and then
there's also the altar of incense which
shows that Jesus is the mediator so they
will pollute the way of salvation in
other words and they shall take away the
daily sacrifices added it's written in
cursive so it's not in the original and
they shall place the abomination that
maketh desolate they will put something
in the place of the plan of salvation in
Daniel 12 verse 11 and from the time
that the daily shall be taken away and
the abomination that maketh desolate set
up there shall be a thousand two hundred
and ninety days and here is a time
prophecy which expands that 1260 day
prophecy by thirty days
take a day for a year the 1260 years
expanded to 1290 the 1260 starts with a
setting up of the abomination that
causes desolation until it comes to an
end and that was from 538 ad to 1798
but the decree to set it up went out 30
years earlier
so it's 1290 days and what was that
abomination that causes desolation well
let's continue mark 13 verse 14 and when
you shall see the abomination of
desolation spoken off by the by Daniel
the prophet standing where it ought not
to let him that readeth understand and
let them that be in Judea flee to the
mountains
when you therefore shall see the
abomination of desolation and Matthew 24
verse 15 spoken of by Daniel the prophet
stand in the Holy Place who readeth let
him understand we need to understand
this issue so in the time of the Jewish
nation the abomination of desolation was
if we look at the parallel text in Luke
the armies of Rome surrounding Jerusalem
Luke 21:20 and when you shall see
Jerusalem compassed with armies then
know that the desolation thereof is nigh
then let them which are in Judea Judea
flee to the mountains and let them which
are in the midst of it depart out and
let not them that are in the countries
enter there into so here was a sign that
God in His mercy had given his church
when you see the abomination of
desolation which in this case was pagan
Rome surrounding God's people to destroy
it and to take its place it should not
happen but that was going to happen it
was a promise then let God's people flee
to the mountains in other words get out
get out of the cities and those that are
in the country should not go back into
the city so apply this to our time and
to the events surrounding it so how did
this happen because when the armies
arrived and they surrounded to rout
Jerusalem there was no way for them to
escape and then for some reason the
armies receded of wrong and they went
back to Rome and the Jewish zealots
inside the city followed them and
started killing the Roman soldiers from
behind which infuriated the
an emperor so three and a half years
later Titus came back with a mighty
Roman army and eventually Rome destroyed
the temple and in that period of three
and a half years the Christians could
escape to the mountains and to the
solitary places they escaped to Pella
and not one Christian died in that siege
of Jerusalem now how does this apply to
the time of the end
now Rome of course has been replaced by
papal Rome which all the Reformers
referred to as the Antichrist system now
if there were two sieges of Jerusalem in
the beginning where the pagans standard
would be set up in the place of the
standard of salvation for God will the
same take place at the end of time and
the answer is yes Rome the Roman
Catholic Church and the system not the
people this system has changed the plan
of salvation it has set up a pagan
standard it has changed God's Word it
has changed the law of God it removed
the second commandment it moved the
solemnity of the Sabbath from the
seventh day of the week to the first day
of the week having removed the second
commandment they had to augment it by
splitting the tenth went into two so
that they have Ten Commandments again
and they will make their standard their
mark of obedience and righteousness
their standard and they will surround
spiritual Jerusalem who stick to the law
of God and the Covenant that God has
made now to sieges were what gave the
opportunity to God's people in the time
of the destruction of Jerusalem to get
out in 1888 there was a move
to introduce a national Sunday law in
the United States of America and Alonzo
T Jones was the one who gave witness
before the United States Senate
Committee on education and labor and
they would have introduced this bill and
they would have arrested those that keep
God's Sabbath and in fact that even
commenced in arresting people who were
keeping God's Sabbath but the arguments
of Alonzo T Jones prevailed and the
Roman threat departed are we living in a
time when Rome is mastering her forces
for a second time we have to keep our
eyes open this is not conspiracy my
brothers and sisters this is the study
of the signs of the times we need to be
aware where of where we stand in the
stream of time Pope Francis in his
laudato si encyclical care for our
common home has asked for the
introduction of Sunday as a day of rest
to give the environment rest and to
allow families to come together this is
in violation of God's law which says
remember the Sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shall you labor and do all your
work but the seventh day is the Sabbath
of the Lord your God so the Roman
Catholic system is asking the world for
legislation to reintroduce Sunday in the
place of God's law
so the abomination of desolation is
again encroaching does it have the power
to do this Pope Francis says that the
pandemic this is now the corona virus
pandemic is nature's response to human
inaction over climate change that to me
is a
amazing so it is nature that we are
concerned with and not the sovereignty
of the God of heaven but Francis says he
believes the Chinese coronavirus
pandemic is certainly nature's response
to humanity's failure to address the
partial catastrophes wrought by human
induced climate change asked by British
journalist Austen every weather the
covered nineteen crisis is an
opportunity for an ecological conversion
the pump but pontiff reasserted his
belief that humanity has provoked nature
by not responding adequately to the
climate crisis who are the powers that
be that he will use to further his
agenda well here's an article Trump
warns the US headed for very very
painful two weeks amid the corona virus
pandemic this is going to be a very
painful a very very painful two weeks he
told the press conference at the White
House
Trump described the pandemic as a plague
I want every American to be prepared for
the hard days that lie ahead
he said now 30 days to slow the spread
and here are three individuals in the
leadership position to make sure that
the public complies to this legislation
that would be introduced now who are
these three individuals well Donald
Trump of course is the President of the
United States Mike Pence is the vice
president and there's a third individual
there and let's look at him he is
Anthony Fauci no doubt Trump will face
surprise infectious disease outbreak now
I want you to look at the day this is
January the 11th 2017
Anthony s Fauci MD director of the
National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases said there is no
doubt Donald J Trump will be confronted
with a surprise infectious disease
outbreak during his presidency in 2017
who is this man
Fauci has led the NIAID for more than
three decades by advising the past five
United States Presidents on global
health threats from the early days of
the AIDS epidemic in the 1980s through
to the current Zika virus outbreaks this
is the man who swings the scepter when
it comes to pandemics and contagious
diseases now it is fascinating to me
that all three of those individuals in
that picture Donald Trump Mike Pence and
Anthony Fauci are all Jesuit trained
individuals they all attended Jesuit
universities and schools it's
interesting that he made this speech in
2017 during a forum on pandemic
preparedness at Georgetown University
which is of course the Jesuit Institute
Fauci said the Trump administration will
not only be challenged by ongoing global
health threats such as the influenza
influenza and HIV but also a surprise
disease outbreak the history of the last
32 years that I have been the director
of the NIAID will tell the next
administration that there is no doubt
that they will be faced with the
challenge their predecessors were faced
with he said while observers have
speculated since the election about how
Trump will respond to such challenges
foresee and other health experts said to
Tuesday that preventing disease
pandemics often starts over
and that a proper response means
collaboration between not only the US
and other countries but also the public
and private health sectors we will
definitely get surprised in the next few
years he said now are these the only
people in this forum
dr. Fauci is dedicated to public service
and formed at Jesuit High School this is
the Catholic courier which boasts about
the fact that the people leading the
administration in the United States are
largely Jesuit trained let's have a look
at Mike Pence to meet Pope Francis in
the Vatican next week this was in
January 2020 and there are some
interesting statements that we can glean
of course as we have stated in previous
lectures this man also has Jesuit
training now details have been released
of the visit Sam Brownback
ambassador-at-large for the
International Religious Freedom was
present at Tuesday's opening session of
the initiative which was described by
Ambassador Gingrich as a dialogue
designed to promote peace religious
freedom and inter-religious harmony
between Christians Muslims and Jews it
was inspired she said by the 2019
document on human fraternity for world
peace and living together a joint
statement of Pope Francis on the grand
Imam and the grand Imam of al-azhar in
Abu Dhabi that was signed in the United
Arab Emirates I find the next one
very interesting karna McGraw are you so
president of the Pontifical Council for
inter-religious dialogue was present at
the gathering according to King Grix
remarks and he said it's fitting that
our discussions should take place at the
Pontifical
Gregorian University which is of course
the flagship Jesuit University Gingrich
said citing st. John Henry Newman that a
Catholic University should aid in the
discernment of truth now this is
incredible the Jesuits were created for
one purpose and one purpose alone and
that is the destruction of Protestantism
there was no crime to base for them to
commit they would do anything in their
power from assassination to whatever
means were at their disposal to meet
their ends and they were to rise in
public office so that they could take
hold of the reins of power so that the
Roman Catholic papal system could be
reinstated in its former glory of
controlling the affairs of humanity it's
interesting that he refers to a Jesuit
University and to John Henry Newman John
Henry Newman of course was the so-called
Protestant that led the Oxford movement
and it is largely because of him that
Protestantism in England was destroyed
and watered down to what it is today
there is no vestige of Protestantism
left left
as a consequence of John Henry Newman
and this apostate Protestant was then
honored by being taken up into the Roman
Catholic system where he became a
cardinal and for his great work of
destroying Protestantism in England he
was declared a saint and the previous
Pope Ratzinger or Pope Benedict had him
dug up and had his mouldy bones in his
hands disseminated all over the world to
be venerated where have we come to that
the mouldy bones of apostate Protestants
should be venerated this is such an
affront to Protestantism that it's
unbelievable but it doesn't stop there
if we look at the Committee on the
judiciary and we're reading there from
the Catholic news agency President
Donald Trump's nominee for Attorney
General William bass said Tuesday that
he does not think his Catholic faith is
an impediment to leading the department
of justice Barr a practicing Catholic
and a member of the Knights of Columbus
was asked by Senator John Kennedy if we
were Catholic and what this meant you're
a Roman Catholic are you not asked in
ADEA of the bar confirmed that he was
Kennedy then asked him if he thought
that this disqualified him from having a
position in the US government some of my
colleagues might think it might kennedy
added Barr replied that if he were the
Attorney General he would render unto
Caesar what is Caesar's did they study
the oath of the Knights of Columbus
which is not too dissimilar from the
oath of the Jesuits this is amazing one
of the first things he did was to
reinstate of the death penalty and the
Bible tells us that the second beast of
the United States of America will make
use of the death penalty when it comes
to transgressing their legislation
around the mark of the beast and we've
had a discussion on that and the mark of
the beast Roman Catholicism was
identified by Protestantism as the Beast
and they clearly state that the mark of
the ecclesiastical power is that they
transferred the solemnity of the Sabbath
to the Sunday now my question is if we
see Jesuit trained people in positions
of leadership if we see the Attorney
General being a knight of Columbus
if we see the
of the administration and even though
our position being very staunch Roman
Catholics and if we go further religion
unplug justice Brett Kavanaugh and the
Supreme Court's Catholic majority as
another Jesuit trained individual even
the Supreme Court is run by Roman
Catholic judges at the moment are we
seeing a second siege and should we be
quiet should we because of echo manacle
relationships keep silent and the world
go on want you knew about these things
people will say to us and you never told
us let us not be dumb dogs that cannot
bark so what are the signs of the end of
the age and where are we standing in the
streams of time Matthew 24 verse 3 and
as he sat upon the Mount of Olives the
disciples came unto him privately saying
tell us when shall these things be and
what shall be the sign of thy coming and
of the end of the world and jesus
answered and said unto them take heed
that no man deceive you for many shall
come in my name saying I am Christ and
shall deceive many
and ye shall hear of wars and rumors of
wars we all know these verses see that
you be not troubled for all these things
must come to pass but the end is not yet
for nation shall rise against nation
etinosa against ethnos which means there
will be ethnically there will be a
racial divide we see it all over the
world God's people should be as far
removed from racism as the East is from
the West God has given us a commission
to reach every tribe and people and
nation in the world in God there is no
prejudice because by one blood he has
hated all people says the scripture
Kingdom against Kingdom so there will be
national conflicts we have them all over
the world there will be famines there
will be pestilences there will be
earthquakes we are seeing all of these
things I'm not going to give a lecture
on the signs of the times this is common
knowledge by now all these are the
beginning of Sorrows
and then the final issue will be they
will deliver you up to be afflicted and
shall kill you that was at the end time
prediction and the end time prediction
this second siege of Rome will
eventually attempt to destroy the last
vestiges of Protestantism on this earth
and what is Protestantism what is a
fundamentalist products then it's one
who believes every word that is written
in the Word of God and one who believes
that the precepts of God are binding to
this very day they shall deliver you up
to be afflicted and shall kill you and
you shall be hated of all nations for my
name's sake
it's not just the coronavirus that is a
scourge in the world today today we have
massive locust plagues which are going
to destroy the food chain in Africa and
already the harm of millions of locusts
on the move is broken by the screams of
farmers and the clanging of pots and
pans but their efforts seem to be in
vain and they're expecting more waves of
these locusts there will be famine we
can expect it this is not fear-mongering
this is a prediction and it's
interesting that Voltaire net asks what
are 30,000 soldiers doing in Europe
without mosques what is this deployment
of a huge military force supposedly for
exercises why are all these things
happening why is the military deployed
everywhere just
to assist but also to control what have
they said in my own country didn't say
say that they will rule with an iron
fist and will not tolerate any dissent
this is not just to distribute mosques
so besides the signs of the times are
there any indications as to how close we
are to the end well let us venture onto
this ground and it's not an easy
decision to venture onto this ground but
if we stick to the Bible and the spirit
of prophecy and do not go down the road
of time sitting then perhaps we should
discuss this issue and the problem is
that so many lectures have appeared on
the Internet
giving times and dates and events as
they will be supposedly happening in the
world and I want to just briefly discuss
some of these so there are a number of
ways in which people are trying to
calculate where we are standing in the
stream of time and some adopt the a
patellas Matic principle now that is a
strange word so let me try and explain
it one of the people who actually use
this a patellas Matic principle was
Desmond Ford and we know of course that
that was highly problematic this
principle affirms that a prophecy
fulfilled or fulfilled in part or
unfulfilled at the appointed time may
have a later recurring or consummated
fulfillment this is what he wrote on the
day of atonement and investigative
judgment in Glacier View manuscript 1980
page 485 so this idea says that the
prophecies that are in the Bible have
more than one application
and can't be well in the future have a
different application now firstly I
would like to state that this principle
is based on Greek philosophy and there
is no internal consistency with
reference to the Bible it would place
Bible prophecy on a par with Nostradamus
and mingle futurism with the biblical
historic continuous method that Jesus
himself used now the way to interpret by
Bible prophecy is to let the Bible speak
for itself and if you go to the Book of
Daniel there is a historic thread
running through the Book of Daniel a
continues historic fulfillment
throughout the prophecy this is the
historic continuous method and this is
the biblical method any other method
puts us on dangerous ground let's see
how Jesus used it Jesus himself used the
historicist method to interpret Daniel
when he announced the time is fulfilled
and the kingdom of God is at hand mark
1:15 this verse alludes to the prophetic
fulfillment of the 70 weeks prophecy of
Daniel 9:24 227 that predicts the
appearance of the Messiah there is a
prophecy that has a time frame and then
states when the Messiah would come and
that prophecy if you calculate it out
comes to the year 27 ad which is the
exact year when Jesus commenced his
ministry was thirty years old but our
calendar is wrong and any children's
encyclopedia will tell you that so that
the time when he was 30 years old was
actually 27 ad so we cannot use that
method this
Della's Matic principle because how
would you apply it
how would you for example take the
images of Daniel chapter 7 which are
historic continuous and tell us how the
kingdoms will arise the first is like
unto a lion Babylon the second like unto
a bear which is medo-persia
the third like unto a leopard with four
wings and four heads that was the Greek
Empire and then the terrible beast which
was wrong and then the ten horns the
European powers that would come out of
that system that is a historic
continuous flow if you wanted to take
that prophecy and apply it into the to
the future then you would have to use
those images and appoint other issues to
those images so you could for example
say well the lion is the symbol of
England today so it must be referring to
England and the eagle would be a symbol
of the United States of America because
that is their symbol and the bear you
could make a symbol of Russia and then
you could come up with whatever you
wanted to put into that's how you use
the prophecies of nostradamus you fit
anything into it and you have no basis
other than conjecture it is dangerous
and we shouldn't go there the second
principle that people use to make time
prophecies are some adopt the Jubilee
principle of calculating the precise
time of the end and they count the
Jubilees from the time of Adam all the
way to our current time and there have
been some lectures in this regard and
some people believe that the coming of
Christ is imminent maybe in the next
year or so depending on how the Jubilees
work out and they take the issues of
exactly when the Pope spoke in the to
the two houses in the United States of
America
they come to those conclusions again how
exactly do you determine it and the
issue becomes so complicated that in the
end you you really struggle to follow
the lines of reasoning now it's very
important that we study the verse which
says that no one knows that day and the
hour let's have a look at that verse
Matthew 24 verse 36 but of that day and
hour knoweth no man no not the angels of
heaven but my father only
now that's fascinating 1 Thessalonians 5
1 but of the times and the seasons
brethren you have no need that I write
unto you for you yourselves know
perfectly that the day of the Lord so
cometh as the thief and the night for
when they shall say peace and safety
then sudden destruction cometh upon them
as travail upon a woman with child and
they shall not escape but ye brethren
are not in darkness that that day should
overtake you as a thief so Paul is
saying that God's people should not be
surprised because they should be
studying the Scriptures and knowing the
time so let us look at this verse in
Matthew again Matthew 24 verse 36 but
the day and the hour knoweth no man and
not the angels of heaven but my father
only
so not even jesus knows the time 9 1865
james white wrote a booklet entitled the
second advent and the code for that book
is SE ADV second Advent obviously and he
has a very interesting study
around this verse there's read what he
writes many hastily conclude from this
text that nothing whatever may be
ascertained relative to the period of
the second Advent but in taking this
position they greatly err in that they
make this class of texts prove too much
even for the unbelief and which at the
same time I raised these declarations
against others uttered by the Savior the
most plain and pointed we object to this
position so when asked about the signs
of the times Jesus gave an abundant
answer in order to explain the
circumstances around his coming so how
is it that we can interpret this text
can anything be learned from the Bible
relative to the period of the second
Advent is a question unsettled in many
minds
this is a grave inquiry and from the
nature of the subject is worthy of close
investigation and candid answer how did
Christ Himself treat the subject when
the disciples inquired what shall be the
sign of thy coming and of the end of the
world
he did not reprove them for prying into
that which was purposely hidden from all
men after all when we go back in history
when the destruction of the world came
in Noah's day
didn't know it tell them exactly what
was going to happen wasn't even the time
predicted 120 years
no he answered them in the most definite
Lanner he even states that there should
be signs of that events and adds when
you shall see all these things know that
it is near even at the doors the simple
fact that the Lord mentioned signs of
his second Advent is the best proof
possible that his people were not to
remain ignorant of the relative men
of the event and to this evidence his
declaration that when these signs should
be seen his people should know that it
was near even at the doors and the case
becomes an exceedingly strong one but of
that day and that hour knoweth no man he
continues no not the angels which are in
heaven neither the son but the father if
the text proves that men will know
nothing of the period of the second
Advent and it also proves that angels
will know nothing of it and also that
the son will know nothing of it till the
event takes place this position proves
too much and I agree with him because if
Jesus is one with the father and is
fully God then he must know the time so
let's see how he resolves this so till
the event takes place this position
proves too much
therefore proves nothing to the point
Christ will know of the period of his
second Advent to this world the holy
angels who wait around the throne of
heaven to receive messages relative to
the pot they act in the salvation of men
will know of the time of the closing
events of salvation and so will the
waiting watching people of God
understand now is he being presumptuous
let's continue an Old English version of
the passage reads but that day and hour
no man maketh known neither the angels
which are in heaven neither the son but
the father this is the correct reading
according to several of the ablest
critics of the age the word no is used
in the same sense here that it is by
Paul in 1 Corinthians
to verse 2 for I determined not to know
can be read make known anything among
you save Jesus Christ and him crucified
men will not make known the day in the
hour angels will not make it known
neither will the son but the father will
make it known there's a quote in the
spirit of prophecy where in early
writings she says as the people of God
looked up and waited for the coming of
Christ the time was made known by the
voice in heaven the father making the
time know so we do not know the day or
the hour he continues and says says
Campbell McKnight argues that the term
no is here used as a causative in the
Hebrew sent of the congregation he field
that is to make known his Christ's
answer is just equivalent to saying the
father will make it known when it
pleases him but he has not authorized
man angel nor the son to make it know
just in this sense Paul uses the term no
in Corinthians 2:2 I came to to you
making known the testimony of God for I
determined to make known nothing amongst
you but a crucified Christ now but
Barnes and his notes on the gospel says
others have said that the verb rendered
knoweth means sometimes to make known or
to reveal and that the passage means
that day and hour none maketh known
neither the angels nor the son but the
father it is true the world has
sometimes the word has sometimes that
meaning as in 1 Corinthians 2 verse 2
that makes a lot of sense because how
would it be possible that he who is very
God and had no beginning Jesus Christ
would not know the hour of his coming
now I'm going to venture onto a ground
that is highly problematic but if we
stick closely to the spirit of prophecy
is there anything that we can glean from
this and this is the concept of the
great cosmic week in other words six
days which become then a day for a
thousand years six thousand years plus
1,000 years for the millennium now this
is a concept that has been around for a
very very long long time and we find in
Psalms 90 and in 2nd Peter the following
statement Psalms 94 for a thousand years
in thy sight or but as yesterday when it
is past and as a watch in the night
second Peter 3 verse 8 but beloved be
not ignorant of this one thing that one
day is with the Lord as a thousand years
and a thousand years as one day the book
of Revelation refers to the
thousand-year millennium period six
times let's look at one of those verses
revelation 20 verse 4 and I saw Thrones
and they sat upon them and judgment was
given unto them and I saw the souls of
them that were beheaded for the witness
of Jesus and for the word of God and
which had not worshipped the Beast
neither His image neither had received
his mark upon their foreheads or in
their hands and they lived and reigned
with Christ a thousand years so there
are six statements regarding this
thousand year period some of them talk
about the devil that was bound a
thousand years now Robert Johnston the
chair of the New Testament department of
the seventh-day Adventist Theological
Seminary of Andrews University a wrote
an article on the subject which can be
found at this webpage and in this
article he shows that some of the early
Advent pioneers most notably Jane
Andrews were actually firm believers in
this principle but that this idea was
later discarded by some including Uriah
Smith it's interesting that as late as
1899 Adventist publications stated
firmly that the end would be sometime
around the year 1900 this belief that
the end will come some time during a
somewhat extended period with an end
point can be called soft time sitting as
contrasted with the setting of a
definite firm date hard time setting so
this is the theology and this theology
although it was used by the early
pioneers was basically discarded and has
well received some very poor press and
people have shied away from it now my
question is does the spirit of prophecy
throw any light on the subject in other
words I know that Jane Andrews believed
it but does the spirit of prophecy throw
any light on the subject and we will
look at some of these and this is not
time setting I'mnot time setting at all
I'm just looking at what does the spirit
of prophecy say and I'm not talking
about the time or the hour and I'm not
interested in any prophetic
interpretation where we take the
prophetic times of Daniel for example
and make them literal times in out dates
there is a system of futurism which is
not in harmony with the bible we're
looking at this cosmic time and i want
to know what does the spirit of prophecy
say they are in fact 4274 if you count
the compilations six thousand year
statements and 41 four thousand year
statements
in her writings now how did I get
interested in this my interest in these
statements comes from us my study of
creation versus evolution particularly
with regard to the age of the earth
however it was proposed by some scholars
that these times are not definitive and
simply meant in other words these 42 or
74 statements on 6,000 and the 41 on
4000 years that they were not meant
definitively and that they actually
meant since the beginning during Old
Testament times but at least one of
these was definitive
when she stated the world is now only
about 6,000 years oh that's in three
spiritual gifts 9 page 92 now Alawite
uses the phrases about 6,000 years 13
times she uses the statement almost
6,000 years once and she uses the
statement nearly 6,000 years 12 times
that they are three where she states
more than 6,000 or over 6,000 and the
rest of the statements just say for
6,000 years now I was part of a
delegation in the church where we
discussed this issue of creation and I
attended a lecture by some of our
prominent theologians where this whole
issue was discussed and it was stated
quite categorically that none of these
statements on the 6,000 years can be
used to determine the age of the earth
now I just come
to this church and I've been an
evolutionist and my whole world was
turned upside down as a consequence of
the study of the prophecies and then
eventually also a study of our origins
and evolution which of course entailed
the age of the earth and as I listened
to these lectures which by the way are
also written in journals these same
sentiments I was confronted with this
idea that there are many statements
which say that the earth is about six
thousand years old or almost six
thousand years old or nearly six
thousand years old but there are these
three statements which state more than
six thousand and therefore this was
presented as proof that you cannot take
them as definitive now this concerns me
and moreover it was stated in those
publications and in those lectures that
where these statements are made about
the six thousand years it's probable
that she was influenced by the margin of
the King James Version which contained
ashes dates and therefore in the concept
of the stream of time or the time period
where they were living it was logical
for her to just adopt these statements
of 6,000 years and it bothered me so I
put up my hand in that meeting and I
said now I just have one problem and
this is the problem if she was
influenced by the margin of the King
James Version to say that it was six
thousand years then what else could have
influenced her in terms of all our other
statements in the spirit of prophecy can
we then still trust the spirit of
prophecy as an inspired source or shall
we just lay it aside well they were
another document which was then
discussed and the issue was explained as
followed yes we believe that she was
inspired but that she didn't have the
same in society as the other prophets
she was as inspired but didn't have the
same Authority now that's an oxymoron
how can you be inspired and not have the
same Authority does God speak through
inspiration with authority only through
some people and with no authority
through other people
was this exegetical or was this
homiletically that was the question well
it bothered me because it disturbed my
apple cart when it came to the age of
the earth i wasn't thinking at all about
what we are discussing today it was at
that time just the age of the earth and
so when I came back to my home in South
Africa and went back to my University
and started working on my lectures on
evolution and creation this thought
bothered me and I prayed and I said Lord
this makes no sense to me
how can it be almost or about 6,000 in
one place and more than 6,000 in another
if there is anything wrong with this
then you must show me because else I
will have to discard virtually
everything she wrote because if she is
influenced by every wind of doctrine out
there then how can I trust the spirit of
prophecy and I filed it in file 13 and
lifted and a few years later a Cole
Porter gave me a little pile of
pamphlets and I read them and I went
through them
and suddenly I almost fell off my chair
because there was one particular
pamphlet that caught my attention but
before I get there here's one statement
that I find interesting from the
biographies in other words this is not
Ellen G wiped writing because it was
stated that Ellen White never ever
received any visions regarding the time
that this controversy or the age of the
earth was concerned but here in the
biographical volumes one bio 366 we read
the following the vision of lava Grove a
higher on a Sunday afternoon in
mid-march 1858 was one of great
importance
in this the theme of the great
controversy between Christ and His
angels on the one side and Satan and his
angels on the other was seen as one
continuous and closely linked chain of
events spanning 6,000 years so in other
words the great controversy vision
actually had this time frame it's
interesting this vision has put
seventh-day Adventists in a unique
position with clear-cut views of the
working of Providence in the history of
our world a viewpoint quite different
from that held by secular historians who
see events of history as the interplay
between the actions of men often
seemingly the result of chance or
natural developments in other words this
vision and others of the great conflict
of the ages yield the philosophy of
history that answers many questions in
prophetic forecasts gives the assurance
of the final victory of good over evil
so it was very definitive so I would
like to look at some of these statements
and what was this pamphlet that I had
received what about the more than or
over 6,000 years
well this pamphlet had the following
information war
eh Don's the seminary librarian at
Andrews University researched this issue
and he came to the conclusion that Ellen
White believed that there were exactly
four thousand years between the creation
of man and the birth of Christ and that
her consistent position was that the
world was less than six thousand years
Oh Warren H Jones L&G white and biblical
chronology ministry April 1984 pages 20
to 22 now personally I do not quite
agree with his statement over here and
we'll talk about why in a moment
because he takes it to the birth of
Christ and I believe that is not the
correct way in which she used it but be
that as it may she clearly believed the
four thousand and the six thousand now
what about those three statements well
the first one is found in historical
sketches page 133 more than 6,000 years
of continual practice referring to the
devil's odds this statement does not
deal with the age of the earth or the
time since the fall but with how long
the devil has been in the deception
business and of course deception started
in heaven which could have been hundreds
of years for all we know so it has
nothing to do with the age of the earth
it has to do with how long the devil has
been in the deception business and after
all he deceived a third of the Angels so
that takes care of that one statement
the second statement is from the story
of Jesus and it says and for more than
six thousand years in its forms of
beauty and gifts of sustenance the earth
has borne witness of the creator's love
now that sounds like it could be
problematic but if you study it this
statement comes from the chapter the
home
of the saved and deals with the new
earth when the earth will be about seven
thousand years old so it has nothing to
do with the six thousand years period of
sin now the third statement is the most
problematic this statement comes from
Christian Temperance and Bible hygiene
page 154 and states the tongue the
continual transgression of man for over
six thousand years now in 1977 dr.
Robert Gentry of Earth Science
associates contacted the white estate
regarding this statement and was told
that this was a copying error and that
the original first source from which it
was taken was three testimonies page 491
492 and did not contain the word over
moreover Ellen White did not use the
word over when she used the earlier
material to write the book desire of
Ages so in other words the three
statements do not negate Ellen White's
stand that the earth is almost six
thousand years
oh now let's have a look and see exactly
what the spirit of prophecy says and
again I reiterate I'm not time setting
I'm studying the spirit of prophecy I
want to know what the Prophet said I
don't want to know what a theologian
thinks the Prophet thought or what
influenced the Prophet I want to know
what did she say so let's ask the
question according to the spirit of
prophecy
how long will send rain well here is a
statement after 6,000 years of sin the
earth was renewed the great plan of
redemption comes from Adventist home
results in fully bringing back the world
into God's favor all that was lost by
sin is restored not only man but the
earth is redeemed to be the eternal
abode of the obedient for six thousand
years
Satan has struggled to maintain
possession of the earth now God's
original purpose in its creation is
accomplished the Saints of the Most High
shall take the kingdom and possess the
kingdom forever even forever and ever
now I want to come back to this
statement at the latest stage but the
point for discussion right here is that
she definitively states that for 6,000
years Satan has struggled to maintain
position of the earth that is a very
direct statement so my question now is
where according to the spirit of
prophecy are we in the stream of time so
when according to the spirit of prophecy
will 6000 years have elapsed since the
fall of man well let's start with the
4000 year statements at Christ's baptism
sin had reigned according to the spirit
of prophecy 4000 years and that was in
27 ad let's make sure because there are
so many of these talks out there which
give dates either calculating as we saw
from the birth of Christ or from the
crucifixion or from any time period in
between I want to know exactly I don't
want to know about what does she say so
let's be careful in the way we approach
it Christ in the wilderness of
temptation let's just stop there what
year was that Christ entered the
wilderness of temptation directly after
his baptism and that was in
27ad it's make sure Christ in the
wilderness of temptation stood in Adams
place to bear the test he failed to
endure here Christ overcame in the
sinners behalf four thousand years after
Adam turned his back upon the light of
his home so since the fall of Adam to
the temptation in the wilderness which
took place in 27 ad is the time period
since the fall of Adam separated from
the presence of God the human family had
been departing each successive
generation further from the original
purity wisdom and knowledge which Adam
possessed in Eden Christ bore the sins
and the infirmities of the race as they
existed when he came to the earth to
help man in behalf of the race with the
weaknesses of fallen man upon him he was
to stand the temptation of Satan upon
all points on which man could be a sail
so exactly 4000 years since the fall of
Adam to the wilderness of temptation
let's read another one the savior of the
world has no controversy with Satan who
was expelled from heaven because he was
no longer worthy of a place there he who
could influence the angels of God
against their supreme ruler against his
son their loved commander and enlist
their sympathy for himself was capable
of any deception for 4000 years he had
been warring against the government of
God and had lost none of his skills or
power to tempt and deceive again here
Satan was going to confront Jesus in the
wilderness of temptation and it had 4000
years to contemplate how he was overcome
Jesus as he had overcome Adam let's make
sure on Jordan's banks the voice from
heaven attended by the manifestation
from the excellent glory proclaimed
Christ to be the son of the eternal that
is the baptism of Jesus where the voice
from heaven came and said this is my
beloved son so we have a date it was 27
AD Satan was to personally encounter the
head of the kingdom which he came to
overthrow if he failed he knew that he
was lost therefore the power of his
temptation was in accordance with the
greatness of the object which he would
lose or gain for four thousand years now
listen carefully
ever since the Declaration was made to
Adam that the seed of the woman should
bruise the Serpent's head he had been
planning his manner of attack we have
precise times in this statement from the
fall of Adam happened to the wilderness
experience of Jesus exactly four
thousand years in other words until the
baptism let us go to the Bible and the
spirit of prophecy when the fullness of
time was come God sent forth his son to
redeem them that were under the law that
we might receive the adoption of sons
Galatians 4 verse 4 and 5 when the
fullness of time had come we need to
know what that is the Savior's coming
was foretold in Eden when Adam and Eve
first heard the promise they looked for
it's speedy fulfillment in other words
that promise that now had taken 4000
years of time to be four-fold they
joyfully welcomed their firstborn son
hoping that he might be the deliverer
but the fulfillment of the promise
tarried those who first received it died
without the site from the days of Enoch
the promise was repeated through
patriarchs and prophets keeping alive
the hope of his appearing and yet
cannot the prophecy of Daniel revealed
the time of his Advent so the prophecy
of Daniel revealed the time of his
Advent from the time that the promise
was made that he would crush the
Serpent's head but not all rightly
interpreted the message century after
century passed away the voices of the
prophets ceased the hand of the
oppressor was heavy upon Israel and many
were ready to exclaim the days are
prolonged and every vision faileth
Ezekiel 12 verse 22 so what were the
conditions prevailing at the first
coming of Christ so we know a time now
exactly 4000 years since the fall of
Adam according to the spirit of prophecy
please note not according to me
according to the spirit of prophecy
exactly 4000 years to the baptism of
Christ
now what were the conditions when the
fullness of time was come God sent forth
his son Providence had directed the
movements of Nations do you not think
that God will direct through Providence
the movement of Nations in our time and
the tide of human impulse and influence
until the world was ripe for the coming
of the deliverer the nations were united
under one government that's an important
point it was the Roman system one
language was widely spoken and was
everywhere recognized as the language of
literature from all lands the Jews of
the dispersion gathered to Jerusalem to
the annual feasts as these returned to
the places of their sahjhan they could
spread throughout the world the tidings
of the Messiah's coming
so let's project to our time the nations
were united under one government not yet
the case one language was widely spoken
English in our time
and the Jews were dispersed through all
nations God has his people dispersed
through all the nations we have many of
these conditions Genesis 11 verse 5 and
the Lord came down to see the city and
the tower this is the Tower of Babel
where humanity was united as one which
the children of men builded and the Lord
said Behold the people is one and they
have all one language and this they
begin to do and now nothing will be
restrained from them which they have
imagined to do so this attempt to unify
God had interrupted in the time when
Jesus came there was almost one nation
ruling everywhere and in the second
coming it could be the same well let's
have a look at this statement and this
is the hundreds blot in Germany and it's
fascinating that they show the EU as the
Tower of Babel with the waters rushing
around it with a coronavirus catastrophe
and here in the corner it says they're
broken I need global a few home we need
a global leadership we need to become
one we are building a Tower of Babel
here they decided to build a city
patriarchs and prophets page 118 and in
it a tower of such offenders height as
should render it the wonder of the world
these enterprises were designed to
prevent the people from scattering
abroad in colonies God had directed men
to disperse throughout the earth to
replenish and subdue it but these Bible
builders determined to keep their
community united in one body and to
found a monarchy that should eventually
embrace the whole one king
one moral leader do we have such a
figure where everybody flocks to him in
Rome for moral guidance and the time
that we are living in thus their city
would become the metropolis of a
universal Empire its glory would command
the admiration and homage of the world
and render the founders illustrious the
Magnificent tower reaching to the
heavens was intended to stand as a
monument of the power and wisdom of its
builders perpetuating their fame to the
latest generation well here is you've
all Noah Harari a very famous author and
he said we will have a totally different
world
after the coronavirus and in this fight
against the pandemic we need one world
leadership catholic arab herald god's
plan is to unite all humanity says the
Pope so the Pope is calling for this
unity here is the Catholic press and it
says the Pope wants all people to be
united because of the corona pandemic
these are important signs which are
leading up to exactly the conditions
that the Bible describes at the first
coming of Christ here is Gordon Brown
one of the former prime ministers of
England he calls for a global government
to tackle coronavirus the former labor
prime minister who was at the center of
the international effort to tackle the
impact of the near meltdown of the banks
in 2008 says we need a global governance
he said only him no Angela Merkel asks
for a new world order these are the
headlines that are screaming at us
Kissinger says even the US can't affect
covered 19 alone his solution global new
world government of course we need a new
world always always preaching about this
the man is now
86 years old and he's still preaching
his new world order and the world will
be different after coronavirus and we
will have the conditions that prevailed
before it might look different I'm not
interested in exactly what this new
order will look like George Bush senior
said no nation will give up one iota of
its sovereignty but the communication
and the way in which things will work
will be different
the Bala drops coronavirus bombshell
it's all due to climate change and he's
the one that supported the Pope when he
came to give his speech he is the one
that made this issue prominent and it's
interesting that out of the gun said
that he has a pact with Putin and that
Trump and Putin and him as a leader of
the Middle East they will create a new
order what that order looks like doesn't
matter we're looking at signs of the
times one of the great signs before the
end is that Satan must impersonate
Christ before the coming of the Lord
Matthew 24 verse 5 for many shall come
in my name saying I am Christ and shall
deceive many and 2nd Corinthians 11:14
and now model Marvel for Satan himself
is transformed into an angel of light a
power working from beneath is working to
bring about the last great scenes in the
drama Satan coming as Christ and working
with all deceivableness of
unrighteousness in those who are binding
themselves together in secret societies
when I read this and I hear all these
people talk about conspiracy theories
conspiracy theories we're not dealing
with conspiracy theories we are dealing
with prophetic fulfillment as the
crowning act and the great drama of
deception Satan himself will personate
Christ the church has long professed to
look to the saviors at
that the consumption of our hopes now
the great deceiver will make it appear
that Christ has come in different parts
of the earth Satan will manifest himself
amongst men as a majestic being of
dazzling brightness resembling the
description of the Son of God given by
John in the revelation this is a future
prediction the glory that surrounds him
is unsurpassed by anything that mortal
eyes have yet beheld the shout of
triumph rings out upon the air Christ
has come Christ has come the people
prostate themselves in adoration before
him while he lifts up his hands and
pronounces a blessing upon them this
comes from the great controversy as
Christ blessed his disciples when he was
upon earth his voice is soft and subdued
yet full of melody in gentle
compassionate tones he presents some of
the same gracious heavenly truths which
the Savior uttered he heals the diseases
of the people and then in his assumed
character of Christ he claims to have
changed the Sabbath to Sunday and
commands all to hell of the day which he
has blessed he declares that those who
persist in keeping holy the seventh day
are blaspheming his name by refusing to
listen to his angels sent to them with
light and truth this is the strong
almost overmastering delusion like the
Samaritans who were deceived by Simon
Magus the multitudes from the least to
the greatest give heed to these
sorceries saying this is the great power
of God so in other words the issue of
papal legislation must already have been
discussed when this appearance takes
place how close are we to this
appearance well isn't it fascinating
that the Israeli rabbi says he's already
holding meetings with the Messiah and
this is from for every xx 2020 this year
Rebbe Rabbi Yaakov Z chokes on Sunday
Toth religious bro
cause the radio mm that Rabbi Kahane
kanisky
recently told him that he can if ski is
already in direct contact with the
Messiah to understand why religious Jews
are taking this seriously it's important
to know that rabbi crime can if ski is
considered one of the two or three top
rod rabbis of the ultra-orthodox Jewish
community in Israel and rabbis eat salt
says that Kaminski and others of the
mystical concealed rabbis have now
tasked him with informing the public of
the Messiah's imminent arrival rabbis
each alts began his explosive three-hour
interview with a warning the process of
redemption is about to start happening
very quickly and at a fast pace the last
events shall be rapid ones it is
important that people remain calm and
steady to act properly in the right time
there is a potential messiah in every
generation and they are righteous men
who know precisely who it is this is of
course true in this generation getting
the word out now but the Messiah is
closer than ever is a matter of life and
death
haven't you heard of Gog and Magog that
is what's going to happen very soon
right now the situation is explosive
more than you can possibly imagine
everyone needs to know whether they are
on the inside or they're going to be
left out and then he went on to
reiterate that a certain rabbi tub cook
as everybody knows is a righteous man he
is one of the greatest men of our
generation ten years ago when Israel was
suffering from horrible drought someone
asked rabbi kook when the Sea of Galilee
will be for recounted rabbis it's odds
rabbi kook responded that when the
Messiah arrives the Sea of Galilee will
be for in a few weeks the Sea of Galilee
will be full for the first time since
Rabbi kook made this statement then I
also
claim that netanyahu will be the final
president now i'm not using this as time
setting i'm using this as background
information that the conditions
described in the scriptures and the
spirit of prophecy are ripe they are
there for us to perceive i do not for
one moment believe in the israel vision
i'm just looking at the signs which we
are informed to do and trying to bring a
message so my question is this if christ
came at exactly four thousand years
after adam sinned and if we add two
thousand years could the world end in
2027 according to this calculation
because remember Christ came twenty
seven eighty when four thousand years
since the fall of Adam had expired and
add to that the two thousand years to
make the six thousand would bring us to
the year 2027 but before I go there and
remember I am NOT time setting I'm
merely quoting the spirit of prophecy I
want to look at that statement that I
referred to earlier and I said we would
come back to it let's look at it
carefully it's a statement about after
six thousand years of seven the earth
was renewed the great plan of redemption
results in fully bringing back the world
into God's favor all that was lost by
sin is restored not only man but the
earth is redeemed to be the eternal
abode of the obedient for six thousand
years
Satan had struggled to maintain position
of the earth now God's original purpose
in its creation is accomplished the
Saints of the Most High shall take the
kingdom and possess the kingdom forever
and ever
even forever and ever what is the
context of this statement well it is
that in the context of the final
restoration when the Saints will possess
this kingdom and the earth forever and
ever so it is after the Millennium when
the earth will be restored to its
original but even after the Millennium
the time period that Satan had been
warring against this government was
6,000 years for 6,000 years Satan had
struggled to maintain possession of the
earth so it's the time frame of his
total struggle now remember during the
Millennium
he cannot struggle he is bound for a
thousand years
he is inactivated he has no power to do
anything so how do we understand this
let us look at Satan preparing for the
final battle this is me writing so when
the wicked are raised Satan must have
some time to prepare them for battle if
2027 is the end of the six thousand year
period of warring against God
then this would exclude the time of
preparation required after the wicked
are raised is it possible I'm just
asking the question that a time could be
cut off from the six thousand years
before 2027 if so then Christ must come
sometime before 2027 to allow this if we
take the prophecies in the spirit of
prophecy as definitive in terms of time
now Romans 9 verse 28 says for he will
finish the work and cut it short in
righteousness because a short work will
the Lord make upon the earth so there
will be a time when he will cut it short
here's another statement in the
prophecy those who are not interested in
the cause of God on earth can never sing
the song of redeeming love above I saw
that the quick word that God was doing
on the earth would soon be cut short in
righteousness and that the messengers
must speed swiftly on their way to
search out the scattered flock we have a
work to do
I want to remind you again this is not
time setting but let the Bible and the
spirit of prophecy speak for themselves
revelation 20 verse 3 says about the
devil and cast him into the bottomless
pit and shut him up and set a seal upon
him that he should deceive the nation's
No More till the thousand years should
be fulfilled so here is a thousand years
of rest complete and after that he must
be loosed a little season so after the
thousand years there is a little season
when he will be active again but by the
time you get to the restoration of the
earth Satan will have been active for
exactly six thousand years according to
that previous statement so now what
about this little season and when the
thousand years are expired 20 verse
seven sacred shall be loosed out of his
prison and he can again commence to
deceive the nations that's the biblical
version now let's go to the spirit of
prophecy this is now after the thousand
years the City of God has come down onto
the surf a plane has been created where
Jesus's feet land on the Mount of Olives
and the city comes down on this purified
area what happens then then Jesus and
all the retinue of holy angels and all
the rich
Saints left the city the Angels
surrounded their commander and escorted
him on his way and the Train of redeemed
Saints followed then in terrible fearful
Majesty Jesus called forth the wicked
dead and they came up with the same
feeble sickly bodies that went into the
grave what a spectacle what a scene at
the first resurrection all came forth in
immortal bloom but at the second the
marks of the cursed are visible on all
this is exactly in accordance with the
Bible description of the second
resurrection the kings and noblemen of
the earth the mean and the low of the
learner and the unlearn had came forth
together all behold the son of man and
those very men who despised and mocked
him who put the crown of thorns upon his
sacred brow and smote him with the reed
behold him in all his kingly Majesty
those who spit upon him in the hour of
his trial now turned from his piercing
gaze and from the glory of his
countenance those who drove the nails
through his hands and feet now look upon
the marks of his crucifixion those who
thrust the spear into his side behold
the marks of their cruelty on his body
and they know that he's the very one
whom they crucified and derived in the
in his expiring agony and then there
arises one long protected wail of agony
and they flee to hide from the presence
of the king of kings and Lord of lords
all are seeking to hide in the rocks to
shield themselves from the terrible
glory of him whom they once despised and
overwhelmed and pained with His Majesty
and exceeding glory they were the one
accord raised their voices with terrible
distinctness exclaimed blessed is he
that comes in the name of the Lord
now what happens next then Jesus and the
Holy Angels accompanied by all the
saints went again to the city and the
bitter lamentations and wailings of the
doomed wicked fill the air then I saw
that Satan again
minced his work so here is a time again
we is going to try and rest the
government of God from him and that
period that he was warring against God
is exactly six thousand years according
to that previous statement he passed
around amongst his subjects and made the
weak and feeble strong and told them
that he and his angels were powerful he
pointed to the countless millions who
had been raised there were mighty
warriors and kings who have skill well
skilled in battle who had conquered
kingdoms and they were mighty Giants and
valiant men who had never lost the
battle there was the proud and British
and bona Polian whose approach had
caused the kingdoms to tremble there
stood men of lofty statue and dignified
bearing who had fallen in battle while
thirsting to conquer as they came forth
from their graves they resumed the
current of their thoughts where it
ceased in death they possessed the same
desire to conquer which ruled when they
fell Satan consults with his angels and
then with those kings and conquerors and
mighty men then he looks over the vast
army and tells them that the company in
the city is small and feeble and that
they can go up and take it and cost out
its inhabitants and possess his riches
and glory themselves Satan succeeds in
deceiving them and all immediately begin
to prepare themselves for battle there
are many skillful men in that vast army
and they construct all kinds of
implements of war that takes time what
kind of weapons will they construct will
they construct swords or are there men
of genius who might construct even
nuclear weapons to try and take on this
enemy then we're Satan at the head the
multitude move on kings and warriors
follow close off the Satan and the multi
you'd follow after in companies each
company has its leader and order is
observed as they march over the broken
surface of the earth to the holy city my
question is how long does it take him to
organize this vast army to put it into
companies to appoint the leaders to
construct the weapons of war that will
be necessary for such a cosmic battle
Jesus closes the gates of the city and
this vast army surrounded and placed
themselves in battle array expecting a
fierce conflict you know if we go to
jesuit theater which is hollywood then
we'll see that there have been many many
movies about an earth totally destroyed
and how they then create all the weapons
and manufacture all the things necessary
for this great final battle where in the
movies they always succeed but in this
biblical story the tables are turned
Jesus and all his angelic hosts and all
the saints with the glittering crowns
upon their heads ascent to the top of
the wall of the city and Jesus speaks
with majesty saying behold ye sinners
and reward of the just and behold my
redeemed the reward of the wicked the
vast multitude behold the glorious
company on the walls of the city and as
they witnessed the splendor of their
glittering crowns and see their faces
radiant with glory reflecting the image
of Jesus and then behold the unsurpassed
glory and majesty of the king of kings
and Lord of lords their courage fails a
sense of the treasure and glory which
they have lost rushes upon them and they
realized that the wages of sin is death
they see the holy happy company whom
they have despised clothed with Gloriana
immortality and eternal life well they
are outside of the city with every mean
and abominable thing and then the Bible
says and fire came down from heaven and
consumed them six thousand years
if it takes time to prepare this army
how long does it take I don't know I'm
not going to make a time so if we are
now in 2020 and the six thousand years
would end in 2027 if we take them as a
continuous period and according to the
spirit of prophecy the six thousand year
period would come to an end in 2027 but
a time period is cut off and added on to
this portion of time when he prepares
his army then how much time will be cut
off I don't know would one year be
enough to organize such a vast army to
build weapons of war to keep people
alive and all the things that are
necessary surely this takes time of
preparation as they watch the city and
prepare is it two years three years four
years five years I don't know but
whatever it is it means we are according
to the spirit of prophecy in that final
week and if that time is cut off then
Jesus must come in the next few years
and therefore the time is short that's
all I'm saying I'm not saying when he's
coming I'm saying it's time is short
Matthew 24 verse 48 says but and if that
evil servant and the servant is someone
that serves in God's church shall say in
his heart my lord delays his coming in
other words when they will say this is
not it this is not the beginning of
Sorrows no we still have time Jesus
won't come for another hundred years two
hundred years I've heard it from so many
people and shall begin to smite his
fellow servants and to eat and drink
with the drunken in other words if they
start attacking those people who say
that the time is short
while they are eating and drinking with
those who are drunk from the wine of
Babylon perhaps they're sitting in
ecumenical councils discussing these
issues and talking about the fanatics
out there who are saying that the time
is short and who are watching the signs
of the times the Lord of that servant
shall come in a day when he looketh not
for him and in an hour that he is not
aware of and shall cut him asunder and
appoint him his portion with the
hypocrites and there shall be weeping
and gnashing of teeth
I've not made a time brothers and
sisters I've just looked at what the
spirit of prophecy says and if those
statements are inspired and not just
influences from whatever source up there
then we have very little time left now
the Lord can add to that time the Lord
delays his coming coming the Lord can
take away from that time I don't know
I'm not making the time I'm saying that
the time is short and if a poor portion
of time is cut off for preparation there
at the end after the Millennium then the
time is even shorter I believe we are in
the closing hours of this Earth's
history and we will see a new world
emerge out of this coronavirus maybe
there will be that time of peace and
then again that repetition of turmoil
that we read about maybe that will take
place I don't know Matthew 24 verse 3
and as he sat upon the Mount of Olives
the disciples came unto him privately
saying tell us when shall these things
be and what shall be the sign of thy
coming and of the end of the world and
jesus answered and said to them take
heed that no man deceive you let no man
deceive you by telling you that the
coming of the Lord is not for many years
to come it's not in accordance with the
signs of the times in which we are
living I can see the forces of Rome must
their powers in the in the excellence of
power up there in governments and I can
see the implementation of the directives
of the man of sin he is calling for all
to come and be educated on the subject
and I believe we are very close to the
end if I am proven wrong then I will be
happy because then we'll have more time
to preach the gospel but if these things
are so and if the profit can be taken at
her word then our time is very limited
let us preach the three angels messages
let us make use of every capacity and
ability that God has given us and maybe
he'll give us a window of opportunity
and maybe not I don't know that the time
is short let's get ready for the coming
of the Lord
let's pray Heavenly Father if these
things are so then our time is short
indeed and lord I pray that you will
prepare the hearts of your people that
they may stand so that they can bring
the loud cry and warn the world just as
John the Baptist a man who was not part
of the great educated class brought the
message at your first coming may
thousands of voices throughout the world
in every nation tribe and Kingdom stand
up and proclaim the soon coming of the
Lord and warn the world to make the
right choice between the precepts of God
and the precepts of man is my prayer in
Jesus name Amen
[Music]
you
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click here when the bell
appears click and you will receive
notifications to watch the next one
click yeah thank you again and see you
next time